thank you guys gonna be here on one of
you I need this where there's times and
I have a lot of confidence right now you
play better by the neck which is pi
where is thank you so much I think
having confidence is important because
without confidence stupid people would
have no idea who to pay attention to and
those are called elections
[Music]
I am very revolutionary think capitalism
is great if you want to do it but don't
make everyone play your stupid game
I like fortnight I don't make a grandma
pudding take away our house of she loses
but some attention elsewhere you're
making cookies grandma I am NOT a
communist but I do support any policies
and Republicans would consider communism
which is whatever two or more people
gather to do something nice
I like how Americans will say communism
never works as a fate that it spent
billions of dollars and killed millions
of people to make sure it wouldn't work
remember Vietnam guys are pretty anxious
about their not working
communism never works because whenever
people control the means of production
their democratically elected leader is
mysteriously denied small-group always
finds automatic weapons themselves I
don't understand these people who blame
immigrants from their problems so like
you know who's taking all my money these
people with less money than me maybe
everybody I'm agent or is it no this
country of Chinese from the problems in
China called South Korea Japan province
about being Asian because whenever
someone is racist to me I'm like oh you
hate respectful people who keep to
themselves
ok finding an affordable car for an
industry hard to avoid us a lot of
people make fun of Asians because we eat
dogs which I just say gonna be very
shocking because in America doctor
treated like family members but in Asia
we feed our family members of other
members
[Laughter]
it was real tradition where instead of
flying an animal we love our grandma
unless she's a baby girl
rules are rules
[Music]
only I am an agent man it's hard to date
you know I wrote those Asian women are
beautiful not everyone takes agent men
are beautiful which doesn't even make
any sense because I think think agent
one that I created I have a crucial part
of the sexy process please stop trying
to get me those dice with me and I
children are very beautiful half of them
well then having a great engineer than
that supportive
I like to eat General Tso's chicken
that's my favorite food stuff and my
Asian friends make fun of me they're
like huh this is that a shitty
Americanized version of something
authentically Asian well yeah I am
single I have yet to meet my soul mate
I've been in today maybe it's her fault
she needs to get out more better my
friends are like Hans you're gonna learn
how to talk to women maybe or maybe
women should learn how to listen to
Holland
why don't you want to hear about the
Federal Reserve for a party come on
I was talking this one lady shows that
did you know that my vagina is a 3d
printer because it can make a baby
accurate your womb is a 3d printer
you'll be doing as the tray I'm even a
very good 3d printer it's one thing with
lots of errors six-night was the bread
once I was printing it's the planing
needless to say they're not city trays
that nice very much
[Applause]